hey welcome to ask IJ
wrong song David oppressing do I wish
that I had a twin Preston
my sister Brianne um no she will never
have a youtube channel she's kind of
busy at pharmacy school during like
really important things as opposed to
making YouTube videos like her sister I
did make her be in with my videos
because you guys are all this really
large person I'm always like what he's
been sort of her purse so I filmed it
Venera right yep what's my favorite
football team
it's my dad's hat stole it I also know
if I like monkeys and if I would like to
receive one in the post I think the best
part about this comment is I love when
non-americans called mail post like I'm
gonna send you something in the post and
now somebody's getting a shower and I
can hear my mom I'm talking downstairs
and I didn't hear my sister over there
writing Brianne are you writing
something it is not an easy task you're
typing it's really hard to shoot a video
at my parents house because there's a
lot of things going on a lot of thing
and now I hear these noises I know
Christmas know if I prefer cucumbers
over pickles I actually hate pickles so
therefore I kind of hate cucumbers
because technically a pickle is a
cucumber
I think it's really cresting what do i
do my spare time I really enjoy doing
nothing or watching TV Dunphy is
starting school tomorrow and wants to
know what my favorite subject was in
high school well you know let me tell
you what my favorite subjects weren't
history math English Spanish that's
subjects
my favor Law & Order character is
definitely Olivia Benson she is awesome
thank you respect okay so I had to share
with you this video response it's
absolutely adorable these two girls
fighting over who loves I just seen more
last episode I asked you guys he thought
that I was a nerd or not a nerd in high
school and obviously this kid is pretty
confident that it was an earth I'm
pretty confident you wear none and he
would be right Brienne was Ayyanar din
high school
what phone what do you have if he didn't
have the iPhone I wouldn't have a phone
at all thanks for watching this episode
bass guy James thought it was kind of
short and a little hectic I'm not at
home so I'm have my camera and I are my
lights and everything's a little bit off
but that's okay if you didn't like it
I have a bunch of vlogs posted on my
other iJustine channel and I'm super
excited because of the episode that I
was in a black box TV is finally out and
it's really amazing everyone did such a
great job so go check that out and let
me know what you think of it also one
last thing thank you to everyone who has
submitted their homework assignments for
vlog e diversity as soon as I get back
to LA I'm gonna post the first actual
episode and yeah that's about it I will
see you guys soon like real soon okay